hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast viruses and soils what do we
know and where do we go from here it is
presented by Laura's inky PhD a
postdoctoral researcher at the
university of california davis i'm judy
ulrich of lab roots and i will be your
moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I would like
to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Zinke I will
now turn the presentation over to her hi
thank you for joining me today
microbiology and immunology library's
virtual event so today I'm going to be
talking about viruses and soils so to
start I wanted to show you a picture of
one of my field sites so the background
of this title slide is Russell ranch
sustainable agricultural Cecilia Davis
California and this experiment says
employed a bunch of different types of
agricultural management and over the
last 25 years and we've been working out
here to do is start to characterize some
of the viral communities and soils
before I get into the science I wanted
to do a quick introduction like Judy
said I'm a postdoctoral researcher at
the University of California Davis I am
focused on studying soil viral ecology
and the newly established Emerson lab
here in the Department of Plant
Pathology and some soil viral ecology
it's a relatively new field I wanted to
take the opportunity today to talk about
why should we study or why should we
care about soil viral ecology so as part
of this overview I want to talk a little
bit about the past of this field so what
has been done up until now to frame what
we're doing currently and then I want to
talk about some of the present things
and so of ireally ecology some of the
really exciting developments that have
allowed us to really start to develop
this discipline as more than a niche
just a plan but really a large part that
we think will become as important as
something like microbial ecology and
then talk about some of the linkages to
viral or between viral ecology and so
chemical cycling including some recent
work that's been done and then I'm I'll
take the chance to talk a little bit
about some of the work I've been doing
here in my postdoc and some of the
directions that I'm taking this work so
why soil viral ecology
that's something that I get asked a lot
and there are a lot of reasons to study
viruses in general starting where the
viruses are very diverse so
morphologically that are quite diverse
if you look at this cancer cell electron
microscope image or TEM image that's on
the screen and this is showing just a
range of viruses from a natural sample
and you see that you have everything
from these qualm filamentous viruses
these much shorter or smaller viruses
but that have these really dramatic
hexagonal capsid heads so in addition to
looking morphological even Birds viruses
are the most genetically diverse or
it's on the planet they go beyond you
know even some of the very diverse
bacteria Nakia where you can have maybe
50% genetic identity between strains
this is viruses don't even have a shared
genetic code some viruses are DNA based
some are RNA based and then they are
different single or double stranded
genomes within those types of genetic
nucleic acid encoding systems so another
reason that we should study viral
ecology is that viruses infect all
domains of life this includes humans as
we've all know especially the cold
season coming up but also viruses will
infect bacteria and archaea so all the
prokaryotes as well so what I'm showing
you here on this slide is kind of a
simplified phylogenetic tree of
different bacteria and archaea from a
sample site that we'll be talking about
in a little bit and then everywhere you
see a red dot means that in this one
study from one site they recovered
viruses that infect these types of
bacteria and archaea so there's a huge
host range in terms of what viruses well
infect another thing that's important to
know about viruses are they're very
abundant
so in marine systems which have been
very well studied compared to other
environmental systems in terms of viral
ecology viruses are usually about ten
times more abundant than bacteria so
even though viruses are tend to be
really small numerically they're a huge
reservoir of diversity on earth and then
something that's near and dear to my
heart so something and I'll be working
on in my postdoc is viruses we think
impact soil chemical cycling and there
hasn't been a lot of work on this
previously but what I'm showing you here
is kind of a simplified diagram of some
of the major biochemical chain
formations in agricultural soils
essentially plants will take carbon
dioxide turn it into plant matter and on
this plant matter or it gets put into
the soil either through route action or
through the plants dying and be
incorporated into the soil and then this
organic matter gets broken down by
microorganisms like bacteria and fungus
it's turned back into co2 and then other
microorganisms can take nitrogen from
the atmosphere and put this into a form
that plants can use so we know that the
microbiome in soils is critical to the
functioning of the soil but we also know
that viruses can infect all levels of
these communities so what are these
viruses doing to these communities are
they you know helping the communities
are they controlling the community
makeup are they hurting the communities
and it's their way that we can perhaps
manage these to better manage our
agricultural systems as well and then I
love this image I think this is a really
striking way to demonstrate one of the
ways in which viruses can impact things
like carbon cycles in this soil so this
is an image of a bacterium getting lice
open by viruses you see the little
lighter colored dots within the darker
squashes those are the viruses that
cause otherwise what were once living
cells to lice open and then they release
all their really nice juicy nutrients
into the soil so this includes things
like sugars and proteins and nucleic
acids and things that other microbes and
plants might want to take Apple contain
something else that's really intriguing
about viruses is that they don't always
immediately kill their hosts so I this
little cartoon is from a review from
2012 that's demonstrating that viruses
can take over their host metabolism
tell a host like a bacterial host I want
you to do this process and they can
alter what things like bacteria or
fungus are actually doing in the soil
and then economically something that's
really important about understanding
viruses and soils is their impact on
crop management and crop disease so I'm
showing you here a picture of soil borne
wheat mosaic virus so this is a solo
borne virus that has a slime mold vector
and this virus can live inside its slime
mold vector and soils for up to 30 years
even after you remove the wheat from
your soil so understanding the baseline
viral community and then also how this
community propagates and survives and
soils over long time periods is really
important when we're trying to do things
like develop that our cropping systems
or better land or soil management in our
agricultural sectors so something I want
to emphasize is knowing that viruses are
in soil is not new we collectively know
that viruses live in soils for decades
I've just captured snapshots of a few
different papers from multiple decades
in which viruses have been previously
studied from soil and you see you go
back to even literature reviews that
came out in 1950 but if you also notice
just from the titles a lot of studies
that looked at viruses and soils focused
on either something like just kind of
general viral transport in soils or
something like a specific fires like you
know specific plant virus or a specific
virus that could infect humans and you
know there's a reason for this it's not
that people haven't been interested in
general viral ecology and soils it's
has been really difficult to study these
systems until more recently so some of
the complications and studying viruses
and soils are actually really closely
related to some of the complications and
studying microbiology in general so here
I have a little diagram of bacteria and
viruses and soils so the bacteria are
the oval shapes viruses are the
hexagonal shapes and there are a lot of
viruses in soils some viral counts but
these that may be ten to the ninth
viruses per gram of soil and a lot of us
are familiar with the idea of the great
plate count anomaly so that's the idea
that if you for instance take a
grandma's soil and you try to put it on
normal plate presented by the tannish
circle here then you'll get maybe 1% of
your microbial component of the soil
actually able to grow on the media that
we give it so that's represented by
these blue ovals that have been able to
grow on this plate and to study viruses
we need to be able to have their hosts
so that we have something for the
viruses to infect and grow in at least
using a lot of traditional viral methods
so for instance if we're only growing 1%
of the bacterial population or only
these blue microbes then we can only
study the viruses represented by the
pink hexagons so what that means
practically is we're missing all of
these viruses in the soil so we have a
very limited view of what viruses are
actually present in soil another reason
why so far we haven't made a lot of
progress and trying to figure out what
viruses are present in soil so there's
no universal marker genes for viruses so
a lot of huge leaps have been made and
more microbial based study like human
micro
studies using targeted sequencing so
sequencing something like the 16s rRNA
gene for bacteria or archaea or the 18s
rRNA gene for eukaryotes but what the
bacterial sorry sorry with viruses since
they're so diverse and they don't even
have always the same nucleic acid that
they use as their primary mode of
genetic recording we can't use these
sort of methods so it's until recently
sequencing on a community level has not
been very easy for viral ecology so what
have we been doing in the viral ecology
field until now so one of the things
that's been really a workhorse for viral
ecology is using microscopy the the
image on the left the one with the green
splotches on the dark background that is
an elephant microscope image of a mixed
viral and bacterial community so you see
that these bigger brighter green things
are prokaryotes and then in the
background these smaller green dots are
viruses so this is one way that we've
been able to tap into and study viruses
by Counting and comparing the number of
viruses picking samples and then on the
right I'm showing you again this TEM
image in which you can identify the
morphology in different viruses so you
can get a qualitative estimate of the
different types of viruses you have at a
very coarse resolution and then from
these sorts of methods the type of data
you get back looks something like this
so it looks like for instance on their
fur the uplift or essence microscopy you
can compare how many viruses are in each
sample so this bar chart on the left is
showing that in some of these systems so
you see to the right are these eaves and
mtk sites followed by
aggghhhhh so those are agricultural
sites that tend to have fever viruses
and some of these undisturbed forest
sites to the left of them and then the
images on your right are data that
results from collecting these different
morphological data using transmission
electron microscopy so you can compare
each bar represents a different mortgage
type or a type of virus and you see that
generally in most of these samples you
have one type of virus in this case the
Poteau Verde are the most abundant but
then in the bottom right hand corner
there's some difference in that and we
see that a different type of virus is
more abundant so this is pretty much
what the field depended on for about 20
years to the study viruses in soils and
recent really fantastic review that came
out in 2017 collated results from all
these different viral ecology studies
and looked at the numbers of viruses
that were found in each different type
of sample so along the x-axis there are
the different types of soil eco types
that were found amongst review these
studies including things like
agriculture and wetland and then on the
y-axis there is the order of magnitude
range of number of viruses in these
soils in grams per dry weight of soil
let me see that you know the natural
systems seen in forests on wetlands tend
to be the most viruses but also things
like cold deserts and agricultural
systems have a fairly high number of
viruses compared to something like hot
desert which might be expected since
that correlates pretty well to the
number of bacteria we expect to see in
these sites and then this study also
looked at the number of bacteria versus
the number of viruses
that were counted in each site and
remember in these better characterize
marine systems that we use as reference
a lot viruses tend to outnumber bacteria
about ten to one but in soils that
apparently doesn't necessarily hold so
for instance and some systems viruses
dominate over bacteria outnumbering and
bacteria up to a thousand to one versus
in other systems bacteria dominate
outnumbering viruses by orders of
magnitude and there is not an apparent
trend between some of these systems so
for instance in these orange bars which
are these desert ii systems there's
quite a bit of spread versus
agricultural systems where in some cases
it appears that viruses dominate and
some bacteria dominate so what this is
really telling us is there's a lot we
don't know about viral dynamics and
soils and there's a lot of work left to
do to try and understand what role
viruses are playing in these different
soil systems and something that's been
really helpful in viral ecology recently
is DNA sequencing so we know DNA
sequencing from a slew of studies it's
really revolutionized the whole field of
biology and viral ecology is no
exception so something you know I
mentioned earlier that DNA sequencing
for a specific gene is not going to work
very well if you're trying to capture a
whole viral community but with the
advent of untargeted sequencing or in
other words shotgun sequencing all the
DNA in the sample this has really been
useful in viral ecology but this hasn't
been applied much as of 2017
so this table I'm showing you is I got
from this soil virus review from 2017
where as of that point the authors had
only found six different studies that
had employed this fact under this broad
sequencing
specifically viral communities so the
type of data we can get out of this
shotgun sequencing is in some ways
similar to the type of data we can get
from easy microscopy so you can see
different numbers of different market
types based on their DNA sequences but
what's really exciting and what I've
been doing is you can take this further
and using all of this data you get you
can start to apply statistical
techniques that are commonly used in
ecology both at the macro scale and used
in more microbial studies and then you
can really start to tackle questions at
a much finer scale resolution than
comparing explicitly the number of
viruses between samples but one of the
first times this was employed was in
2007 and this is work that was done by
noah fuhrer and it he found that from
sequencing three soil samples and
comparing them to some of the few others
specifically viral sequencing efforts at
that point soil samples were unique and
distinct from other environments so this
was I think surprising I would have
expected soil to be more similar to
seawater or marine sediment men sea
water sediment are to the human gut but
in light of more recent findings and the
microbial ecology field we're starting
to see that soil is actually this really
different environment that has a whole
slew of different factors that go into
viral ecology that make it distinct from
environments that are better
characterized so that brings us to today
so currently we're in what I'm calling
the Renaissance the soil viral ecology
so what does that mean in addition to
this becoming a really you know broad
field where you have a lot of different
groups let's understand finally viruses
are we can do things that make us a
really robust science
so we can do a lot more samples at once
so instead of comparing maybe three
different soil samples like we saw in
the 2007 study a couple of slides ago we
can now sequence hundreds of samples at
once and we can also do a much higher
depth of sequencing for each sample and
so what this means is that instead of
sampling a specific virus your viral
genome maybe once or twice in a sample
we can sample it essentially hundreds of
times and become really confident about
what we're looking at so what these two
points mean is that we now have more
spatial and more temporal resolution so
instead of being able to compare soils
from different states maybe we're now
starting to compare soils from within a
couple of feet of each other or like
what I'm doing where we compare soils
from different parts of the same
cropping field we can also start to
study temporal dynamics so maybe that
might explain some of these large
variations we see in the bacteria ratio
versus the viral ratio and then this
higher depth the sequencing per sample
means that we can begin to recover
complete viral genomes so instead of
getting a little snippet of DNA and
trying to draw conclusions based on that
which is sort of analogous to giving one
piece of a puzzle and trying to figure
out what the whole puzzle looks like we
can now recover these complete viral
genomes and be able to say I think this
is what this virus is doing I think this
is who this virus might infect and I
think that we can draw these conclusions
based on these other factors and
compared to the environment so to
highlight some of these recent
developments I wanted to go through a
study that was published last month in
Nature microbiology this is a study done
by Jo Ann Emerson who's my postdoc
advisor and some of her collaborators
from the ISO geni project which has been
looking up falling permafrost
so as a quick background permafrost is
permanently frozen ground but with
climate change right now we are having
significant thawing of permafrost and
this hasn't happened in a long time so
we're not sure what to expect from this
are we going to see increased methane
emissions from these sites are we going
to change the carbon cycle on earth
things like that remain open questions
so one thing we wanted to or the authors
wanted to do was to study the viral
ecology of this and see what row viruses
are playing so the map here with the red
arrow is showing where this study was
done so you see this is in northern
Sweden college store Dahl and Meyer and
the image on the bottom left-hand side
is the kind of a panoramic view of the
study side so you see that this doesn't
look that cold right now it has some
beautiful trees a lot of lakes in some
areas that are kind of boggy and thawed
so a close-up view of this shows where
the samples were taken so what the
authors did was they went to this
thawing permafrost area and they took
soil samples from different areas that
have been thawed to different amounts so
for instance all these brown dots you
see towards the top of the picture are
from what's called Paul's ax that's the
most frozen type of soil and then
there's a thaw gradient up so you could
spend which is more just kind of like
watery but barely thawed soil and by
taking soil samples they were able to
collect 201 metagenomes from this
thawing permafrost soil so this means
that they collected samples they
extracted all the DNA from the samples
and they sequence them using a variety
of on in theory unbiased methods and
then once all of these meta genomes were
sequenced and there
there's DNA ranging from mosses to
bacteria than these metagenomes or
bioinformatics is and so in other words
viral genomes were retrieved from these
total soil genomes and from this the
authors recovered almost 2,000 complete
or near complete viral genomes which is
a huge number but only 17% of these
viral genomes could be taxonomically
identified so what that means is only
17% of these viruses are related to
something where we know what the virus
does and we have studied this virus
somehow usually through cultivation
based methods so if you look at the pie
charts on the bottom of the slide you
see that the green wedges are the
taxonomically classified viruses total
17% most of the viruses were are either
unclassified but have been seen in other
environments typically in other soil
environments or have never been seen
before and this is the first time that
the sort of virus has been recovered
from a sample so we see that there's a
lot of soil virus diversity and we don't
know what these viruses are doing or why
they're there essentially so then using
some different biome chromatic
techniques including looking at CRISPR
energetics sequencing spaces and where
viruses were if they were inside of a
host genome then they've integrated
themselves into the genomes the authors
of the study were able to connect the
viral portion of the community to some
of their hosts so this is again this
phylogenetic tree of all the bacteria
and archaea that were found in these
samples and where all these red dots are
are where viruses that probably infect
these microbes were found and the
numbers next to the dots show how many
viruses were found that infect these
hosts so for instance two
far left you see the Proteobacteria with
the number 148 this is a really common
type of bacteria and a lot of viruses
apparently infect these bacteria so you
can start to determine not just how many
viruses are there but also how they're
impacting the microbial community and in
total 35 percent of the almost 2,000
viruses that were recovered were able to
be linked to a host or in other words
just something about like a bacteria
Dell infects and the hosts included
things like methane cycling organisms
including ones that will produce or
consume methane and also heterotrophic
organisms who do the bulk of organic
matter cycling organic matter breakdown
in soils so this is exciting we're
seeing about potentially by infecting
hosts who do really critical chemical
transformations in the environment the
viruses could be impacting how hosts are
cycling these chemicals and then there
is also finding that viral communities
from these different types of permafrost
thawed soils so the more thawed like the
Fen in blue versus the least thawed like
the pawls a-- in brown are actually just
inked of between the soil types so these
were compared to some of the different
other parameters like who the hosts were
or what the ph of the soils were or how
much moisture is in the soil and there
is a significant correlation found
between some of things like the host
community or the viruses or sorry the
bacteria that the viruses are infecting
and the viral community so that's
linking these viruses and who they
infect and also excitingly
it was found that viruses are
corresponding to pH which is something
that a huge meta-analysis of all the
bacterial communities and soils that
we've seen found with bacteria and we
see that also pH not only affects
bacteria but also viruses
and then the last point I want to
highlight from this paper is that
viruses and coded glycoside hydrolases
so glycoside hydrolases are these
enzymes that will break down organic
matter including organic matter produced
by plants so what some of these
glycoside hydrolases include hydro
enzymes that will break down different
parts of plant materials so everywhere
you see a red arrow next to these
hexagonal cartoon sugar structures is a
place where virus encoded high delays
will cleave so what this means is that
viruses are also helping to break down
organic matter in these thawing
permafrost soils into smaller sugars
that then the bacterial rqd can bear any
tiller eventually becomes something like
carbon dioxide or methane so really what
this study showed that viruses are
impacting nutrient cycling in permafrost
soils but building on from that I want
to know how viruses are impacting
nutrient cycling and agricultural soils
so located in kind of inland northern
California I'm in an area where there's
a lot of tomato farming and that's
something that UC Davis is really good
at is growing tomatoes especially in
long term experiments and things like
that so I have this really great
opportunity to sample soils and study
virus communities from soils that have
been maintained organically for crop
production for 25 years as well as soils
that are maintained and kind of your
conventional or industrial agricultural
settings and biochar amended tomato
field soils so what biochar is
is similar to charcoal it's you can take
things like waste products from
agriculture like almond shells or walnut
shells or pine needles and you can heat
these up to evolve the chemistry of
these materials and then web-spinning
evolve some of the gases can be used for
biofuels or biogas and what you're left
with is essentially chard or ashed
organic matter and this can be buried in
the soil and this will do a couple of
things this can be used for carbon
sequestration so putting carbon back
into the soil and a form that will
probably not be broken down very quickly
and it can also be used to retain soil
moisture or nitrogen but there's still a
lot of uncertainties in terms of what
biochar or how biochar interacts with
soils including within the living
components of soils so that's something
that we're actively studying right now
is looking at soils from different types
of biochar amendments so biochar that
was made from different food sources
like almond shells versus pine needles
and how this is impacted the viral
community so to do this what we do is
they start out going out to the field so
we sample soil from tomato fields and
I'm showing you a couple of pictures of
our sampling back in July where we have
one of our fantastic undergrads come and
help and let us sit back and watch her
do the dirty work and so that's the
picture on the left and then the picture
on the right I'm holding up the bag
freshly sampled soil so then once we get
this soil back to the lab we do a couple
of things to it
we still quantify so we still do counts
of viruses under the eppela freslin
microscope to try and figure out how
many viruses are there so how we do that
is you separate the bacteria and the
viruses from soil and then we take this
separated back
area and buyers full liquid and we pass
it through a point two micron filter so
what that does is that filter will allow
viruses and other small particles to be
separated from the larger cellular
community like the bacterial community
and we can centrifuge this we get
exclusively viral particles and then we
can stain these with a nucleic acid
stain and put them under the microscope
and we get something that looks about
like this so this is an image from our
two fantastic undergrads who have been
working on trying to make these
microscopic counts really robust and
repeatable and interestingly preliminary
numbers are showing we're getting
somewhere around 10 to the 7 viruses per
gram of soil which is a little bit on
the lower end but this is also sampled
at a point kind of later in this season
so this so it was a little drier there
might not be as much living in there so
this is exciting this is starting to
really allow us to connect the viral
counts or how many viruses are there to
the actual viral ecology and then what
I'm focusing on in my postdoc is taking
these viruses and further concentrating
them so that we can extract their DNA so
what this looks like is ultracentrifuge
and viruses to get them out of solution
for several hours and extracting their
DNA and sequencing that as well as we
look at and sequenced the total DNA of
the soil so this includes the bacteria
and the fungus and then we run all of
these sequences through a bioinformatic
pipeline that looks about like this so
once you have DNA and you sequence it
you get back using the technology we use
which is a woman of high seek sequencing
we get back DNA fragments that are about
125 to 150 base pairs long and that's
pretty short that's not always super
our informative about that length so
what we do to make more sense of this
data is we will assemble these fragments
in other words we will try to
reconstruct genes from these smaller
pieces of DNA and then from these
reconstructed genes we filter out the
sequences that are too short to be
confidently called as viruses and then
we do another check to ensure that all
of our sequences are from viruses and we
use a program called vs order to do that
and once we have all of our sequences
that we think are viral we can start
getting into the real science of it so
you can ask questions like who are these
viruses or who are these viruses
infecting we can ask questions about
their function so what are these viruses
doing do they have these extra metabolic
genes to tell their hosts to do
something for instance with the
glycoside hydrolases that were found in
the permafrost study and we can start to
look at relative abundances of viruses
so our by a specific type of virus more
abundant during the summer when fields
have Tomatoes actively growing
where are they more abundant during
winter when there's maybe not anything
growing in that field and some really
preliminary work that we have from some
of these tomato field soils that have
biochar in them is that there are quite
a few viruses in these soils so I'm
showing you here just a quick bar chart
with the different types of soil
amendments on the bottom so this
includes a control that's just normal
tomato soil or the normal soil that we
plant tomatoes in here in Northern
California Tech is soil that's been
amended with charred coconut shell pine
or almond shell and what we found from
this is that the number of viruses is
high and it's actually quite diverse so
we recovered over 3,000 viral
populations from over 6,000 viral
genomes so
that saying is we recovered about 6000
viral genomes and that about half of
those are unique within the dataset so
in addition to taking that study further
and really delving into who those
viruses are and what they're doing some
of the other work I'll be doing in my
postdoc coming up in the next year is
comparing viruses between organically
managed and conventionally or
traditionally managed soil so in
conventionally managed soil fields you
usually get some sort of fertilization
from like a liquid mineral fertilizer so
you get your nitrogen in the forms of
like nitrate ammonium like inorganic
forms and pesticides could be used for
pest management first it is and the
organic soils the fertilizer all comes
from chicken manure or from a cover crop
is planted in the winter like a lagoon
that will put nitrogen back into the
soil and some work out some of our
collaborators so it's done have already
shown that this will have changed on
microbial communities so we're
interested in this has changed the viral
community and justice have any impacts
on the functioning of the soil so how in
general chemicals are cycled in the soil
or in terms of how this could impact
plant health
so are there viruses that can either
promote plant health by say killing
plant pathogens or are there viruses
that are pathogenic to plants residing
in the soil and then within this will
also be comparing seasonality of soil
viral community so do these communities
change with this season and we suspect
that they do but stay tuned we'll get to
that and that is all I have to say for
today and I really want to thank you for
your time listening and I also want to
thank some of my friends house to glad
me it's a collaborator API dr. Emerson
are at UC Davis who have been
responsible for getting all the biochar
fields set up and running thank you Dr
zenki for that informative presentation
we will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box it appears on the screen
and click the send button our speaker
will follow up with your questions via
email so let's get started our first
question is what are some of the major
limitations in viral ecology and how do
you address those yeah so like any field
new or well-established there are
several drawbacks that we really need to
consider when doing our studies I think
one of the most major ones is a problem
that we also have on micro ecology where
through studying anything without
culturing it we don't we're dependent on
things that have been cultivated to
understand what they're doing so as long
as we have for instance a gene that's
been previously studied then we can
compare what we find in our novel
systems and compare to what's been
previously studied and say okay we think
that this is doing this because they
look similar or they have similar
sequences but we also get a lot of DNA
sequences where we have no match to them
and those are going to be really hard to
figure out what they're doing just from
looking at a DNA sequence so that's when
we have to go back in to our samples and
try and recover those and actually
culture those so that's I think one of
the biggest drawbacks right now is we're
really limited in terms of what we
previously studied for comparing that to
what we currently are studying
and one of the other big drawbacks that
I'm having with my work is that since
viruses are so diverse in terms of if
their DNA based or RNA based and they
have different doubler single-stranded
nests it's hard to in one study target
all those different types of viruses so
I'm focusing mostly on DNA viruses right
now but for instance a lot of plant
viruses are RNA viruses so that's
something we're actively working on
being able to simultaneously examine but
there's still some methods development
that's going into that well thank you
for that next one is what are some of
the applications of soil viral ecology
so I think there are quite a few I think
they're all a little bit maybe a decade
off in the future but some of the things
that people are doing now that's really
exciting is trying to use viruses that
occur naturally to control pathogenic
plant pathogenic viruses that are sorry
um pathogenic bacteria and fungi and
things like nematodes and smaller or
naturally so that does not impact a plan
or a human and introducing it into an
environment to infect a fungus that does
negatively impact a plant is something
that's preliminary been really
successful in some sectors and there's a
lot of evidence that we can also do that
with things like mosquitoes or with
other pests including human pests and
that's why I think it's really important
to keep studying viral ecology since to
do something like that we also need to
know what are the other viruses in the
system and how will be impacting a whole
system so we don't accidentally you know
start a domino effect or anything very
interesting thank you for that next one
is our viral communities in soils
positive or negative for the environment
yeah so that's something I actually get
asked a lot so we
this view from including from a bunch of
really entertaining movies that viruses
are bad you know when you think of virus
do you think of something like the cold
or the flu and and I mean in humans and
pathogens
you know those viruses are bad but I
think what's going to happen with our
impression of viral ecology is it's
going to be similar to what's happened
in the past ten years with looking at
bacteria for instance in the human gut
or in agricultural soils where we know
that there's a small portion of these
entities bacterial or viral that aren't
good for us or for plants or something
like that but actually there are
probably a lot that are really
beneficial and critical to something
like nutrient cycling or controlling
populations of bacteria or other
organisms that keep something from you
know blooming and going out of control
and yeah so I think I mean it's
definitely going to be dependent on the
situation and the virus and what your
application is but I think in general
viral populations are a really
beneficial thing to have in the
environment good we have time for one
more question do human activities impact
soil viral ecology yeah so we don't know
yet
from some of the preliminary studies so
for instance the graphs I was showing
where there's different numbers of
viruses and different types of soil that
seems to indicate that in some cases we
might decrease the number of viruses
present in some of the soils so it looks
like we could have an impact on that we
also know from other systems so from
things like sewage or wastewater
treatment that humans can help to
increase the number of viruses in a
given place but again that's something
that we're not totally and hopefully
something bad through some of my work as
well as a working
a lot of a really fantastic scientists
well thank you I would like to once
again thank dr. Zinke for her
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through December 13th 2018 you will
receive an email from laberd's letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that is
all for now thank you for joining us
we hope to see you again soon bye